few philosophical schools or movements
have been as influential as that of
neoplatonism it conceives of existence
as consisting of different levels or
realities beginning with the highest
reality called the one or tohen the a
concept that cannot be understood or
described in any way this one then
emanates or flows over into something
called the news often translated with
words like intellect or mind news then
also emanates into the so-called Soul or
Obsession which in turn create our
physical Universe of time and space the
neoplatonists then conceive of a return
and the goal of a human being is to turn
away from physicality and the material
traveling Inward and contemplating his
true noetic reality thus returning to
her home in the news and they're
experiencing a mystical Unity with that
noose and even maybe ultimately with the
one itself